let's go down to another interview
that is absolutely chilling Donald Trump
says that the reporters who broke the
story on Roe v Wade getting overturned
should be jailed and forced to give up
the name of the Supreme Court leaker
this was an interview with the
right-wing Sebastian Gorka hard to
imagine a friendlier interviewer to
Trump and it is just absolutely bone
chilling Catherine Engelbrecht the uh
the heroine and the hero of 2000 mules
her partner Greg Phillips were arrested
for refusing to give up their souls how
come they don't do this with the leaker
the leaker of the Supreme Court because
if you went and got to that reporter
that's a terrible thing that happened it
puts you on justices at tremendous risk
and that continues so they can't find
the leakers very easy to find the liquor
if you did the same thing to the
reporters you did to Catherine
Engelbrecht he's a great woman uh you
say we want to know who the leaker was
because the leaker gave the story to
this reporter so so why aren't you doing
that yeah so as you can see a very
healthy respect here for freedom of the
press and independent journalists now
they're lying to you by the way you know
they talk about oh but other peoples
have been other people have been jailed
when they didn't give up their Source
the true the vote leaders were jailed
after being found in contempt for not
complying with the legal judicial order
to identify a believed criminal behind a
data breach at the heart of these
conspiracy claims regarding China and
our elections it was not about
journalistic sources it was about
identifying a criminal a believed
criminal completely different situation
altogether just does it doesn't make any
sense Phillips and Engelbrecht declined
to name a particular individual because
of the conspiratorial belief that the
guys in FBI informant which is just
crazy they're just Bonkers people they
were escorted out of a courtroom by U.S
Marshals it's it's has nothing to do
with what Trump and Gorka are talking
about here it is a chilling attack on
journalism and Independence of media and
then Trump talks about General Mark
milley and the infamous walk to the
church uh and it's it's just insane so
Millie was weak when I heard what he did
because what he walk in with the
president he should have said this is a
great honor the president held up a
Bible and many people why should why
should a general
praise
of religiously tainted Stunt by a
president why is that what Millie has to
do well I'm very proud to have been in
that group but yeah
was when he when I heard him give an
apology I said he's gone and he was gone
he was weak he was in effect and he's
woke and now I understand he I watch him
talking about white privilege and how
terrible everything is and you know it's
just it's not even believable that a guy
uh could have gotten to that place yeah
listen anybody with a good head on their
shoulders would have seen that Bible
walk stunt where they cleared the
protesters and walked to the church with
Trump holding up a Bible any reasonable
person would have seen that and said
that looks like a fascist I'm not saying
he is one or that the country has gone
fascist but that looks like the imagery
of a fascist of totalitarianism it looks
horrifying and we should all be against
it but Trump is mad that Millie didn't
suck up to him and go wow sir this was
such an amazing thing scary scary stuff
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part go shop plant-based bags to replace
single-use Plastics all over your home
you'll save 20 20 percent when you go to
hold on bags.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below